good afternoon welcome back to Monday
motivation with my good friend dr.
Serena HN a colleague of mine from I RMS
in Livingston New Jersey I'm Alice
Creasy co-founder and CEO of many
answers creator of the fertility answers
app platform
now there's seemingly nothing else going
on in the world right now
beyond coronavirus we know this right it
has become pretty difficult to go about
life as usual when never in our
lifetimes
I don't think Serena have you or I ever
seen whole cities in different countries
locked down when we've seen containment
from Ebola we've seen containment you
know for we've seen pregnant women leave
cities to protect pregnancies from Zika
we've never witnessed something like
this before so you know I hate to say
never but like I remember vaguely stars
and MERS and and didn't really come over
here right didn't yeah we think so I
feel protected yeah it seemed like some
big news far away and now people are are
really feeling it here although there's
a lot of reassuring data in the United
States despite the fact that they are
identifying more cases and they are
doing more travel restrictions I think
there's there's still a lot of things
that are reassuring about the situation
in the United States now I don't want to
belittle what's going on at all but I do
think it is important to remember that
healthy people pregnant women and
children do not appear to be susceptible
to getting a severe case of the virus
it looks like the deaths so far in the
United States and have been people who
are already very very vulnerable to
viruses anyway which are the elderly
with cold something we like to call
comorbidities which usually raised up
like I you already have a chronic lung
disease you already like
copd and more comfort you know back when
you're on chemotherapy your usual heart
failure so really like you have a
serious serious underlying illness it
does increase your risk of deaths
honestly from any infection and
coronavirus is no exception to that now
it does make like feel like your level
of exposure though makes the difference
too because we do have healthy first
responders who did have have succumb to
coronavirus that seems to be more
related no underlying health conditions
to the level of exposure you know when
they've been yes exactly which which no
average person would ever have that
level of inoculation a certainly not
with you know whole festivals like South
by Southwest being canceled you know and
those those you know really big public
environments where you could have you
know just extreme amounts of viral kind
of passage from person in person now I
also was reading that there's that
people aren't really showing symptoms
until about five days after they've been
exposed right but I read recently a lot
of people get really crazy about that
because they're just thinking everybody
around them has cooties and they're
gonna get it back right when you're
asymptomatic you are not you're not
really shedding as much right remember
this virus can only attach to
respiratory epithelium which people get
confused about people think it's in the
air and they're gonna breathe it and
then they're gonna get sick but what
happens is when people cough or sneeze
if their acute if they're ill or they're
shedding virus the virus can live on
surfaces for about a week and we are
touching surfaces
all the time and then we are touching
our faces and the ports of entry are the
mouth the nose and the eyes because the
mucous membranes and the eyes can are
attached to the nose and
we lead to the oropharynx so this goes
back to you know biology how
everything's connected there so those
are the ports of entry that's how you
get to the virus gets to the respiratory
epithelium it doesn't go through your
skin you can't really breathe like
somebody who's who's in another room and
then as you if you breathe the same air
it's not airborne right you're literally
just leave your face alone that's why
washing your hands you know makes such
is the most important thing and the hand
sanitizers out but they face open water
for 20 seconds is better anyway then
water is really the number one best way
to sanitize your hands
hand sanitizer is only helpful if you
don't have good easy access to a shirt
right right so right and we're seeing
these crazy things where people are are
like to buying out all the em sanitizer
meanwhile there's tons of soap in the
stores yeah so it definitely makes sense
and is this run in the grocery stores
maybe is because the CDC told people at
risk that they should be prepared to
stay home so if you have severe heart
disease the CDC doesn't want you going
out they want you to have part of your
healthy relative or your healthy friend
go to the grocery store for you instead
of you going out so there is some advice
on the CDC website about making sure you
have supplies to be able to stay at home
if you are vulnerable to coronavirus but
not really for people who are healthy
okay
so right it's run in the grocery stores
doesn't really make medical stunts